[Applause]
Paul nice to see you again this time in
person I know exactly do not over Zoom
it last time I talked to you I was in
building this movie I know I know and
you looked fabulous then you look
fabulous now so you've directed movies
with strong female casts like
Bridesmaids Ghostbusters
now this one so I assume that's not a
coincidence did you have like strong
female like empowering people in your
life growing up yeah I mean most of my
friends growing up were were girls and
then women as I grew up and I was really
I was an only child really close to my
mom and I just got tired of watching
movies where women had one-dimensional
character especially comedy we were too
yeah exactly especially when I got to
Hollywood and I became friends with so
many you know comedic actresses and just
you know actors and I would they were so
great I'd see them in a movie and they
were playing you know the shrewish
girlfriend or the terrible wife and not
going to be funny and not getting to
have a good role and I was just like I
hate this and I love telling women
stories anyway so it's just I I there's
nothing else I want to do in my career
well you're killing it yeah
look at who I get to work with bro you
know it's an amazing past yeah job well
done casting whoever did that
um how was it working with Paul you said
you'd worked with Paul before obviously
so you'd work them before but how is it
working with him different than maybe
other directors he's effortlessly uh
collaborative oh that's awesome yeah
it's it's I sometimes as an actor I feel
like I'm putting everybody out
certainly not well what about this what
about this what if we don't do this what
if and Paul never makes you feel that
way Paul is excited by ideas and
um
it's exhausting sometimes I don't know
how he does it because actors can be a
lot so it's really nice when there's a
sincerity behind the collaborative
nature that he brings to the side but I
love it I mean that's the only way I can
work with women you know I'm not like
like I have some great Insight in into
women's stories and how you know how
everybody thinks but I collaborate you
know that's like how you know here's
what I want you to do and they're like I
don't know if it would be like that oh
cool how is it so then we're a constant
collaboration and that's how it should
always be it should be men and women
working together so we both avoid
stereotyping each other both ways we
just found out how you've been married
so long
it's funny which is always a plus he's
so funny he's just the natural ability
so making movies are long and tedious
and it's a it's a real gift when you get
to work with people that can make you
laugh thank you yeah what about you was
it your first time working together it
was yeah it was we'd been wanting to
work together for a long time and we had
developed as producers together but I
never acted with or for Paul and I was
really excited I'm such a huge fan when
the first time I saw bridesmaids I was
like oh Christ who is this director how
do I get to go to this party
um and will anything ever top the
bathroom scene I don't know I don't know
I don't know but I don't think so
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody